>> Ben: I AGREE WITH BILL
McGURN'S SENTIMENT BUT I DON'T
THINK THAT HEADLINE IS GOING TO
FIT.
BRET: I DON'T THINK SO.
>> Ben: GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME
TO "FOX NEWS PRIMETIME."
♪
>> Ben: YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT THE
NAZI BOOK BURNING, THE BANS, THE
CENSORSHIP, THE OPPRESSIONS OF
THE THIRD REICH.
HAVE YOU SEEN THE IMAGES, BLACK
AND WHITE FOOTAGE OF CHANTING
BELIEVERS, FLAMES FLYING HIGH
THEY ARE IMAGES OF EVIL AND YOU
KNOW HOW THEY END.
FEW PEOPLE KNEW THESE BOOK
BURNINGS WEREN'T SOME BIG
GOVERNMENT CRACK DOWN.
LOOK CLOSER AT THOSE DARK AND
GRAINY IMAGES THAT YOU HAVE
SEEN.
MOST OF THE PARTICIPANTS AREN'T
SOCIAL DISTANCING OR POLICEMEN,
SMILING, LAUGHING YOUNG PEOPLE.
IT WAS A FUN TIME FOR THEM.
THEY WERE ON THE RIGHT SIDE OF
HISTORY, THEY THOUGHT.
THEY WERE PART OF SOMETHING
BIGGER THAN THEMSELVES.
THEY DIDN'T KNOW WHAT WHAT THEY
WERE A PART OF WOULD SWALLOW
EVERY ONE OF THEM BY THE TIME IT
WAS FINISHED.
FEW PEOPLE REMEMBER THAT THE
BOOK BURNINGS OF THE GERMAN
1930s WERE LED BY STUDENT
ACTIVISTS WHO STARTED WITH THEIR
OWN CAMPUS LIBRARIES.
THEY DIDN'T WANT THE BOOKS THAT
CHALLENGED THEIR DELICATE MINDS.
A LOT TRIGGERED OUR YOUNG LITTLE
NAZIS WHEN THEY RAN OUT OF
CAMPUS LIBRARIES THEY CAME FOR
THE INDEPENDENT BOOK STORES.
THE GOVERNMENT, HAPPY TO HELP,
ONLY CAME IN LATER.
DOES THIS SOUND FAMILIAR?
THEY WERE THE VANGUARD BUT THE
PEOPLE IN POWER DID AGREE WITH
THEM.
IF YOU WERE READING THE "NEW
YORK TIMES" ON APRIL 7TH, 1933,
AND THAT FRIDAY MORNING YOU
FLIPPED TO PAGE 11 YOU WOULD SEE
CONDENSED IN A FEW SHORT
PARAGRAPHS THE NEWS THAT THE
NAZI GOVERNMENT HAD BANNED PARTS
OF THE OLD TESTAMENT THEY DIDN'T
LIKE.
THEY WERE MAKING MOVES TO
CONSOLIDATE THE PROTESTANT
CHURCHES INTO A NEW STATE
VERSION OF CHRISTIANITY COMPLETE
WITH ITS OWN SAINTS.
THEY WERE STARTING A NEW
RELIGION.
JUST BELOW THAT A WIRE FROM THE
"NEW YORK TIMES" BERLIN
CORRESPONDENT TOLD OF THE
MONARCHIST NEWSPAPER WARNING
THAT THE CATHOLIC CHURCH WOULD
NOT BE SO EASILY ROLLED AND
GERMAN CATHOLICS WOULD NOT ABIDE
THE POPE BEING REPLACED WITH A
GOVERNMENT MINISTER.
SO THE NAZI GOVERNMENT BANNED
CATHOLIC PUBLICATION IN THE
COUNTRY.
MOBS DID THE GOVERNMENT'S WORK
FOR THEM.
SOMETIMES THEY DRESSED UP IN
LITTLE UNIFORMS.
IN THEIR DRESS AND THEIR TACTICS
THEY MIGHT STIR RECOLLECTIONS
AMONG A FEW PEOPLE IN PORTLAND
WHO REMEMBER THE SAGA OF THE
INDEPENDENT BOOKSTORE POWELL'S
BOOKS WHICH THIS WINTER HAD THE
AUDACITY TO FEATURE REPORTER
ANDY NGO'S WRITING ON THE
VIOLENCE TO SETTING THEIR CITY
AT THE HAND OF BLACK CLAD THUGS.
THE THUGS THREATENED THEM FOR
THIS AND THE BOOKSTORE WAS
AFRAID.
NO ONE IN PORTLAND WAS GOING TO
STAND UP FOR THEM.
IF YOU LIVED IN PORTLAND, WOULD
YOU COUNT ON THE POLICE TO
PROTECT YOU?
THE POLITICIANS MAKE SURE THEY
CAN'T.
THE BOOKSTORE WAS PROTESTED,
COVERED IN SIGNED, FORCED TO
SHUT ITS DOORS EARLY AND
THREATENED.
SO THE OWNERS FOLDED TO THE MOB.
ANDY NGO WHO HAS BEEN ON THIS
PROGRAM WOULDN'T SEE HIS BOOKS
ON THEIR SHELVES AFTER ALL.
IF CUSTOMERS WANTED IT THEY
COULD GO ONLINE.
THIS WEEK NGO WAS NEARLY BEATEN
TO DEATH AGAIN.
NO PROMISE AUTHORITIES ACQUIESCE
TO THE MOB RUNNING THEIR CITY.
WE ALWAYS PRETEND TO LEARN FROM
OUR HISTORY AND ASSUME WE ARE
SOMEHOW MORE ENLIGHTENED THAN
OUR ANCESTORS THAT THEY ARE
EVIL.
WE ARE FIT TO MAKE OUR OWN RULES
AND OWN HISTORY TO BAN IDEAS.
BANGEORGE WASHINGTON AND HUCK FN
AND DR. SUESS AND THOSE CATHOLIC
TEACHINGS THAT INCONVENIENCE US.
WE ARE EXPERTS NOW.
WE HAVE GOT THIS AS GEORGE
McDONALD WROTE THE ONE
PRINCIPLE OF HELL IS I AM MY
OWN.
THE FIRST THING TYRANTS DO WHEN
THEY ARE IN CHARGE IS BAN
SPEECH.
BUT NOT JUST ANY SPEECH, THEY
BAN THE SPEECH THAT THREATENS
THEM.
OFTEN IF A GROUP THAT THREATENS
THEM IS POWERFUL OR INFLUENTIAL,
THEY WILL GIVE THEM A CHANCE TO
FOLLOW THE RULES, DO THE GOOD
THING.
THERE IS THAT RIGHT SIDE OF
HISTORY.
NAZIS WANTED THE CHURCH TO STICK
TO ITS OWN BUSINESS.
DON'T SPEAK OUT ON POLITICS.
DON'T MEDDLE IN THINGS YOU DON'T
UNDERSTAND.
STAY BEHIND YOUR PULPIT, PRIEST.
LET THE YOU GIN NIST SCIENTISTS
THE MODERN MEN DEAL WITH THE
THINGS THAT MATTER.
LEAVE IT TO THE EXPERTS.
AND IF THE LEADERS OF THE
COUNTRY WANTED TO OPENLY REJECT
CHURCH'S TEACHINGS, WHO ARE YOU
TO SPEAK UP?
IN THE BOOK OF ECCLESIASTES WE
READ THE WARNING WHAT HAS BEEN
WILL BE AGAIN.
WHAT HAS BEEN DONE WILL BE DONE
AGAIN.
THERE IS NOTHING NEW UNDER THE
SUN.
EVERY DAY WE SEE THE SIGNS OF A
NEW FANATICISM IN OUR COUNTRY
AND THE EAGERNESS TO JOIN WITH
THE NEW MOVEMENT.
SOME OF THE DAILY DEVOTIONS ARE
ABSURD AND LAUGHABLE LIKE
MSNBC'S RELIGIOUS WEARING TWO
MASKS WHILE YOU JOG AS A SIGN OF
YOUR LOYALTY TO THE WOKE REGIME.
SOME OF THE DEVOTIONS ARE FAR
MORE TROUBLING LIKE THE BANNING
OF BOOKS EXPOSING THE
TRANSGENDER'S REAL HARM FOR
TROUBLED CHILDREN OR REPORTERS
STARING AT HUMAN CATASTROPHE ON
OUR BORDER WITH HUMANS ARE
CONTROLLED AND RAPED BY
SPRAWLING CRIMINAL GANGS WHO
TURN AROUND TO THE CRIMINAL
CAMERAS TO LIE TO YOU ABOUT IT
AND TELL YOU THEY ARE JUST
CHILDREN BEING VICTIMIZED BY THE
MEAN AMERICAN POLICEMEN.
THE RULING CLASS DOESN'T NEED TO
DO EVERYTHING ITSELF.
THEY CAN PICK AT THE PERIPHERALS
AND NOD IN AGREEMENT WHILE THE
MOB AND THE STUDENTS, THE
CORRUPT CORPORATE PRESS AND THE
TECH OLIGARCHS GET THEIR HANDS
DIRTY.
YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED TO TALK
ABOUT THE WUHAN LAB LEAK UNTIL
YOU ARE.
THE PRESS AND THE OLIGARCHS SAY.
WE HAVE ALWAYS BEEN AT WAR WITH
EAST ASIA.
THE WORDS OF E.J. "ACCESSER" A
DEAD THING CAN GO WITH THE
STREAM ONLY A LIVING THING CAN
GO AGAINST IT AND WE'RE THOSE
STUBBORN AMERICANS WHO ARE ALIVE
AND AWAKE GO AGAINST THE CURRENT
AND NEW WOKE RELIGION.
THE LEFTIST OLIGARCHS WILL USE
THEIR POWER BOTH GOVERNMENT AND
DORPT CRUSH THEM.
SO THEY WILL TEACH THE NEW RACE
HATE TO OUR STUDENTS, OUR
SOLDIERS AND OUR DIPLOMATS.
THEY WILL MOCK THE VATICAN FOR
CALLING FOR CLERGY TO HOLD SIN
TO ACCOUNT FOR THE SAKE OF THE
SINNER BY FLYING THE RAINBOW
FLAG FROM THEIR EMBASSY.
THEY WILL TELL THE HISPANIC AND
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE SUFFERING IN
GUATEMALA THAT THEIR PROBLEMS
STEM FROM RACISM AGAINST
AFRICAN-AMERICANS AND
LGBTQBIAS.
WE ARE A FREE PEOPLE BECAUSE WE
UNDERSTAND WHERE OUR RIGHTS COME
FROM.
AS GEORGE WASHINGTON SAID IN HIS
FAREWELL ADDRESS.
REASON AND EXPERIENCE BOTH
FORBID US TO EXPECT THE NATIONAL
MORE RATTLE CAN PREVAIL ON
EXCLUSION OF RELIGIOUS
PRINCIPLE.
THIS ISN'T IT.
IT'S ESSENTIAL.
WITHOUT FAITH WE COLLAPSE AS A
PEOPLE AND AS A COUNTRY.
THE LEFT COMES FOR RELIGIOUS
AMERICANS NOT BECAUSE THEY WANT
TO ABOLISH RELIGION, BUT BECAUSE
THEY WANT TO REPLACE IT WITH
RACE POLITICS, WITH SIGN TIM AND
SCIENCISM AGENDA PILE BIBLES
HIGH AND TURN THEM INTO ASH.
AND, YET, THE LIGHT SHINES IN
THE DARKNESS AND THE DARKNESS
DOES NOT OVERCOME IT.
IT WON'T.
IT CAN'T.
AND WE, AS FREE AMERICANS, WILL
MAKE SURE IT NEVER DOES.
I'M BEN DOMENECH AND THIS IS THE